[Aplausos]
[Música]
argentina sí sí a argentina otra vez
vuelve a estar en el candelero de verdad
queridos amigos os di mi palabra no es
que visual polític nos hayamos enseñado
con este país ni que le hayamos puesto
en la diana ni nada por el estilo pero
es que qué queréis que os diga la
argentina el país que durante la primera
mitad del siglo 20 fue la gran potencia
latinoamericana no deja de darnos malas
noticias por ejemplo hace relativamente
poco tiempo os contamos aquí en este
canal los estragos que estaba causando
la cuarentena más larga del mundo y es
que en el momento en el que preparábamos
este vídeo aunque ya no fuera tan
estricto los argentinos llevaban ojo más
de 250 días de confinamiento o actividad
restringida algo que como os podéis
imaginar está afectando duramente a la
economía una economía que ya venía
teniendo muchos pero que muchos
problemas incluso para los cánones
argentinos desde el 2018 así que podemos
decidir que el coronavirus ha sido así
como el golpe de gracia un golpe muy
duro que está teniendo ya muchas
consecuencias y una de ellas es
precisamente una oleada de empresas que
se están planteando seriamente abandonar
la argentina aún cuando yo pudiera
implicar las grandes pérdidas económicas
claro que viendo el panorama que hay
pues muchos están pensando que quedarse
podría llegar a ser mucho peor
pero que empresas y por qué se están
planteando realmente abandonar la
argentina en qué momento exacto se
encuentra este país bien en este vídeo
os contamos todos los detalles una
potencia en potencia amigos cada vez que
hablamos de argentina os prometo que nos
resulta casi imposible dejar de
sorprendernos por su incapacidad para
escapar de lo que ya abiertamente
podemos denominar como el problema de la
crisis permanente al fin y al cabo si lo
pensamos finalmente la argentina es un
país con un potencial enorme una
población preparada mucha actividad
cultural un clima razonablemente bueno
muchos recursos naturales un país
extenso etcétera etcétera la lista de
atributos positivos es muy pero que muy
larga y desde luego está que nosotros
mismos experimentamos no es una
sensación nueva ni tampoco es algo que
nos pase y sólo a nosotros
ah
[Música]
ya en la década de los 60 y mira que ha
llovido el más tarde premio nobel simon
kuznets afirmó que había cuatro tipos de
países de acuerdo a su desempeño
económico los países desarrollados los
subdesarrollados la argentina y japón la
evolución económica de los países que
estaban en los dos primeros grupos se
podía explicar pues sin muchos problemas
pero en el caso de japón y argentina hay
amigos en ese caso su evolución era
exactamente la opuesta a lo que se podía
esperar japón para bien y argentinas
para mal por su parte otro premio nobel
de economía paul samuelson describió en
1980 la situación argentina de esta
manera fijaos si alguien me hubiese
preguntado en 1945 qué parte del mundo
espera usted que experimente el más
dramático despegue económico las
próximas tres décadas probablemente yo
habría dado una respuesta parecida a la
siguiente argentina es la ola en el
futuro tiene clima templado su densidad
de población ofrece una dotación
favorable de recursos naturales por
empleado por un accidente histórico su
población actual constituye la más
homogénea progenie de las naciones de
europa occidental y la argentina de 1945
se encuentra en ese estado intermedio de
desarrollo del cual se puede fácilmente
esperar un rápido crecimiento amigos
quizás podríamos definir a la argentina
como una oportunidad perdida y no una
vez sino varias veces
[Música]
sin embargo la argentina errequeerre
lleva desde los años 40 desde la
emergencia de juan domingo perón
aplicando prácticamente las mismas
políticas con los mismos resultados es
algo de lo que ya os hemos hablado en un
montón de vídeos de hecho durante el
advenimiento de la democracia en 1983 la
argentina ha estado gobernada por el
peronismo durante 25 de los últimos 37
años y en la provincia de buenos aires
que es la más grande y poblada de todo
el país durante 29 de esos 37 años casi
el 80 por ciento del tiempo y bueno es
que además para colmo el resto de
gobernantes después tampoco es que se
han distanciado mucho de unas políticas
que ya casi podríamos considerar tan
típicas de la argentina como la pampa el
asado el choripán o el chimichurri bien
el caso es que ahora en 2020 se han
juntado dos elementos capaces de poner
nervioso al más rudo inversor el
coronavirus y un nuevo gobierno amigos
el 10 de diciembre de 2019 asumió la
presidencia alberto fernández aunque
bueno no está realmente claro hasta
dónde llega su poder y hasta donde el de
su vicepresidenta la poderosa señora
cristina fernández de kirchner
[Música]
en cualquier caso la cuestión siendo
justos es que alberto fernández llegó a
la presidencia de un país muy dañado en
unas condiciones muy precarias porque si
la herencia que recibió mauricio macri
en su día no fue precisamente buena la
que él mismo dejó no tuvo nada
absolutamente nada que envidiar la os
hemos hablado de ello con todo detalle
en un anterior vídeo aquí en visual
político alto desempleo alto gasto
público mucha inflación y una
considerable caída en las reservas del
banco central prácticamente todos los
indicadores estaban en rojo rojos
rojísimos
[Música]
y para colmo a los dos meses estalló la
crisis de coronavirus que puso patas
arriba a la economía mundial y que está
dejando en argentina casi como un solar
las previsiones más prudentes apuntan a
una caída del pib del 12 por ciento
durante el 2020 una tasa de desempleo
por encima del 22% un índice de pobreza
cercano al 45 por ciento y una inflación
que puede superar la barrera ojo del 50%
en otras palabras más que de la
'tormenta perfecta' deberíamos estar
hablando casi de todo un tsunami
económico en un país además que lleva
desde el 2012 de mal en peor pero bien
antes hemos hablado de la herencia
recibida pero lo cierto es que las
políticas del actual gobierno pueden
poner las cosas aún peor atentos
[Música]
espaldas al mundo el gobierno argentino
tiene un plan único para salir de la
crisis un plan tan único como peculiar
en tanto en cuanto supone hacer lo
contrario de lo que han hecho la mayoría
de países que han atravesado una crisis
para salir de ella pero queréis algunos
ejemplos pues bien echemos un vistazo a
dos de las políticas del presidente
alberto fernández con más impacto en la
economía argentina en primer lugar
tenemos los controles de cambio y es que
veréis el gobierno argentino utiliza la
emisión monetaria esto es la conocida
popularmente como máquina de hacer
billetes para financiar buena parte del
gasto público
no
es algo que el gobierno argentino lleva
haciendo desde hace décadas de tal forma
que el valor de la moneda local
prácticamente ha desaparecido por
completo esta es la causa de la enorme
inflación que año tras año azota al país
y también de que los argentinos siempre
busquen huir al dólar si buenos aires es
uno de esos lugares donde puedes lograr
descuentos si pagas en monedas
extranjeras
[Música]
pues bien para tratar de frenar el
hundimiento del peso el gobierno aplica
controles de cambio de esta forma si
quieres comprarnos dólares en el mercado
oficial a unos 80 pesos por dólar
tendrás que reunir una serie de
requisitos lo cual suele resultar
difícil por eso la alternativa es el
mercado negro donde el dólar no cotiza a
80 pesos sino a 145 además si eres una
empresa que se dedica a la exportación
el gobierno te arrebata los dólares que
recibes y te los cambia en pesos al tipo
oficial de unos 80 pesos pero al caro si
luego quieres comprar otra vez dólares
pues no ser por ejemplo para pagar unas
importaciones y no lo consigues en el
mercado oficial entonces entonces tienes
que hacerte con ellos en el mercado
negro a 145 pesos la pérdida como veis
es de casi el 40% además por si fuese
poco las empresas extranjeras lo tienen
muy pero que muy difícil para sacar los
beneficios cosechados del país
así que ya veis que fácil lo que se dice
fácil pues los exportadores y los
inversores en argentina pues que no lo
tienen
[Música]
luego tenemos el régimen laboral que si
en argentina ya es de por sí costoso
durante la pandemia incluso se han
prohibido los despidos fijaos por
ejemplo en estas palabras de alberto
fernández como dije en el g20 nadie se
salva solo hay que ser solidario y
ponerse en el lugar del otro y ayudarlo
algunos miserables olvidan a quienes
trabajan para ellos y en la crisis los
despiden a esos miserables les habló el
papá francisco ahora les digo yo que no
dejaré que lo hagan
alberto fernández amigos no nos
engañemos todo esto puede sonar muy
bonito pero la realidad suele ser algo
distinta imagina que tienes una empresa
que ahora por la pandemia vende menos o
no vende absolutamente nada si no puedes
hacer ajustes de plantilla o recurrir a
fórmulas para reducir las pérdidas
aunque sea de forma temporal entonces
puede que toda la empresa termine
cerrando y echando a todos los
trabajadores si la realidad a veces no
es tan bonita pero si le das la espalda
tienes un problema pero en cualquier
caso estoy seguro que coincidiréis
conmigo en que no parece los mejores
mensajes para alentar la inversión en el
país no nos parece pues eso no es todo
si a la crisis por la que atraviesa el
país al tipo de políticas que se han
puesto en marcha durante lo que llevamos
de 2020 le añadimos las que ya estaban
en vigor como por ejemplo
en uno de los tres países del mundo ojo
uno de los tres países del mundo con los
impuestos más altos a las empresas
entonces ya podemos entender por qué
muchas compañías que están empezando a
plantearse salir corriendo o al menos
frenar en seco cualquier inversión bueno
y de hecho según un informe de la onu
argentina hay ahora incluso antes de el
coronavirus el segundo país con peor
evolución de la inversión extranjera
directa en lo que va del siglo 21
imaginaos ahora y ojo que no se trata
sólo de las empresas
de acuerdo a una encuesta realizada por
la consultora ataque on research
strategies
junto con las compañías inclusión y
gestión aplicada ocho de cada diez
argentinos que tiene la posibilidad de
proyectar sus problemas a 10 años se
irían del país y tuvieran las
condiciones para hacerlo los argentinos
con capacidad de pensar a largo plazo
están pensando en irse
[Música]
por otro lado en septiembre del 2020 el
financial times publicó un informe en el
que plantea la salida de un número
creciente de empresas extranjeras del
país por ejemplo el corresponsal de este
periódico en buenos aires contaban como
al mismo tiempo que el ministro de
economía martín guzmán presentaba el
presupuesto 2021 con unas proyecciones
relativamente optimistas la compañía
chilena de ciclos comerciales para la
vela anunciaba su progresiva salida de
la argentina empezará por cerrar
inmediatamente 4 de los 19 locales que
tienen el país mientras busca comprador
para el resto de las operaciones pero
amigos dicho esto seguro que muchos de
vosotros estáis pensando pero agravar
enrique no se tratara éste de un caso
aislado algo puntual de verdad que hay
más empresas que quieren dejar un
mercado de 45 millones de personas pues
y lo cierto es que sí y cada vez son más
las empresas que se lo empiezan a
plantear ahí tenemos el caso de las
aerolíneas por ejemplo en el mes de
junio la aerolínea de origen chileno la
tan confirmó su salida del país y
comenzó a negociar con sus 1.700
empleados llegaba a la argentina 15 años
mantenía vuelos a 12 destinos locales y
una participación del 16 por ciento del
mercado
[Música]
a la también seguirnos y la que ha
confirmado que incluso una vez se
restablezca la normalidad aérea ya no
prestará servicios de conexión entre
nueva zelanda y el país gaucho
exactamente lo mismo que ha anunciado
qatar airways emirates por su parte
anunció en agosto la suspensión por
plazo indefinido de sus operaciones y
norwegian ha vendido sus operaciones
domésticas en el país
y no se trata solo de las líneas aéreas
o paralelas otras muchas empresas de
sectores muy distintos se están
planteando seguir los mismos pasos claro
que la mayoría se muestran muy
cautelosas porque evidentemente quieren
reducir la conflictividad y al mismo
tiempo intentar colocar o vender sus
negocios vemos que las empresas chilenas
se han porque hay un claro sesgo anti
mercado anti empresa entonces es
preocupante que la administración de
alberto fernández siga en esa línea juan
sutil presidente de la confederación de
la producción y el consumo chile por
cierto ha sido entre 1990 y 2016 el
segundo mayor inversor en argentina
después de brasil bien en cualquier caso
algunas empresas en cierta forma ya han
anunciado sus intenciones que es decir
que se piran o al menos que reducen
considerablemente su presencia queréis
saber cuál es pues arranquemos con la
lista
la empresa química oriunda de eeuu bass
ha anunciado el traslado de buena parte
de sus operaciones a brasil lo mismo que
ha hecho la francesa saint gobain que ha
trasladado la producción de parabrisas a
brasil y cerrado su fábrica de la
localidad de campana en la provincia de
buenos aires durante el mes de julio el
laboratorio francés pierre fab vendió
sus instalaciones y dio por concluida su
actividad en el país lo mismo hizo la
empresa alemana de embalajes y
suministros farmacéuticos hettsheimer
y seguimos brightstar un fabricante de
teléfonos móviles para marcas como
samsung o lg que tiene una planta en río
grande con 500 empleados ha cerrado la
venta de sus instalaciones de producción
en el país a cambio de la simbólica
cifra de un dólar si un dólar digamos
que la prioridad era marcharse a
cualquier precio por su parte una
empresa más conocida knight anunció ya a
principios de año que traspasaba a sus
operaciones en el país junto a la de
brasil chile y uruguay a la empresa
mexicana axo luego el también gigante
norteamericano walt market tiene 92
establecimientos repartidos en 21
provincias y que da empleo a más de
10.000 personas pues también ha
confirmado que busca marcharse por
completo estaba buscando un comprador
para sus actividades argentinas claro
que el problema que tienen es
precisamente encontrar un comprador una
misión que cada vez resulta más
complicada de hecho este parece ser el
mayor escollo al que se enfrentan las
multinacionales extranjeras pero es que
aquí ni siquiera termina la historia
todo apunta a que además de las que
hemos mencionado empresas como sodimac
burger king starbucks también dejarían
argentinas y encontrarán a alguien que
se hiciera cargo de esos negocios
amigos esta tendencia aparece en la
última etapa de un largo proceso que ha
hecho que argentina se convierta en un
país al que la inversión extranjera le
tiene alergia para que os hagáis una
idea el país gaucho pasó de representar
en torno al 20 por ciento de toda la
inversión extranjera que llegaba a
latinoamérica a menos del 5% y
evidentemente que una empresa extranjera
se marche del país es una mala noticia
los grandes grupos internacionales
tienen mayor capacidad para invertir un
mayor nunca un sistema de gestión más
modernos y habitualmente más tecnología
así que si se marchan pues te quedas sin
ellos mientras que los grandes casos de
éxitos económicos del mundo lo hicieron
atrayendo inversión y en otros muchos
lugares encontramos noticias como estas
un cantón suizo pronto superará hong
kong como el mejor paraíso fiscal del
mundo para las empresas hong kong pronto
perderá su estatus como el lugar con el
impuesto corporativo más bajo del mundo
y será reemplazado por el pequeño cantón
montañoso de habitual de suiza grecia
ofrecerá una exención fiscal del 50 por
ciento para los profesionales que
regresan y los migrantes digitales el
caso de argentina es único porque este
país aspira a salir de su crisis
interminable haciendo exactamente lo
contrario ahuyentando la inversión
extranjera fijando más impuestos más
controles de cambio y mucha mucho
y sima más regulación quizás
precisamente por eso sea una crisis
eterna no nos parece pero llegados hasta
aquí turno para ti qué futuro crees que
le aguarda a la argentina logrará
superar la crisis y si nos estás viendo
desde este país que sois muchos por
cierto cómo valoráis la gestión de
alberto fernández que pensáis que
debería cambiar déjanos tu respuesta
aquí abajo en los comentarios y ya sabes
si este vídeo se ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like i suscribiros a visual política
una vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]